ok Jo documentaire réalisé par Philippe
baron ou comment à l'automne 1944
l'écrivain l'aiguillou est devenu vous
venez de le voir le témoin privilégié
d'histoire sombre de la Libération celle
de viol et demeurtre commis par des
Giants sur des populations civiles
françaises de quoi s'interroger plus
au-delà sur un sujet longtemps très
longtemps passé sous silence les
violences sexuelles commises en temps de
guerre et c'est ce que nous allons faire
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débat doc avec vous pour
commencer Julie le gars bienvenue vous
êtes historienne maîtresse de conférence
à l'Université de Paris Nanterre votre
dernier ouvrage coécrit avec Nicolas
patin s'intitule Guerre mondiale le
désastre et le deuil c'est un ouvrage de
publier chez Armand Colin véronique
naomgrap est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes anthropologue et
éthologue spécialiste des crimes de
guerre et des conflits de
l'ex-Yougoslavie et de la Tchétchénie on
y reviendra avec vous bien sûr dans un
instant sur ces conflits relativement
récents et jusqu'à un grand nombre de
viol sur cette période jusqu'à l'Ukraine
jusqu'à l'Ukraine bien entendu Julie
LeGac néanmoins on va revenir sur ce
qu'on vient de voir ce film que nous
avons vu ensemble car ici c'est un
épisode qui est finalement pas si connu
que cela des Français depuis quand
est-ce qu'on s'est intéressé au viol et
au violon sexuel commises par les
soldats américains lors de la libération
alors c'est vrai que c'est un sujet
assez peu connu même si on voit qu'il y
a une mémoire locale qui est très ancrée
on voit l'émotion de ces descendants de
personnes qui ont été victimes de ces
crimes pendant la guerre on s'est
intéressé
surtout avec un certain nombre d'études
qui sont publiées autour dans des années
1990 2000 on revoit cette image des
soldats américains qui étaient présentés
uniquement comme des héros comme des
libérateurs et où on écorne un peu le
mythe et on voit que certes ce sont des
libérateurs mais qui se sont comportés
également comme des conquérants qui ont
commis des comités qui s'agissent de
pillage ou voir sous l'emprise de
l'alcool notamment des violences sur
l'ensemble de la population et en
particulier sur les femmes avec des
violences sexuelles le documentaire
parle de 152 procèdent ce type
du côté de
l'armée américaine en réalité ce sont
17000 viols et violences sexuelles qu'on
qui ont été répertoriées par un
historien qui s'appelle Fabrice Virginie
notamment alors des violences sexuelles
commises à la fois en Angleterre et
notamment avant le débarquement on l'a
vu dans ce documentaire en France durant
la libération et au fur et à mesure se
libérer les territoires et jusqu'en
Allemagne bien entendu c'est un chiffre
aujourd'hui communément
acceptée ce chiffre d'environ 17000
viols effectués par des Jays de la même
américaine la question des variations
est très compliquée très problématique
puisqu'on a vécu on a plusieurs types de
source on a effectivement les
condamnations judiciaires qui sont la
face émergée de de l'iceberg qui est qui
sont liés
en premier accueil les femmes n'osent
pas forcément porter plainte du fait de
la honte n'a pas envie que ce qui leur
est arrivé soit connu de leur entourage
ensuite il faut que les plaintes soient
recueillies acceptés il faut qu'ensuite
qu'il y ait poursuite du crime et
éventuellement condamnation ce qui
impose de trouver des preuves
suffisantes pour condamner on va revoir
si vous voulez bien un extrait du
documentaire puis je viens vers vous
tout de suite après sur ces
condamnations de de ces soldats
américains lors de la libération en
Bretagne
la potence mobile se déplace de village
en village
et au pays de la guillotine l'US Army a
dû faire venir un bourreau du Texas
[Musique]
avec dans ce témoignage d'une
historienne américaine ce sous sujet
finalement qui était la ségrégation dont
souffrait les soldats afro-américains
y compris sur ces questions au sein de
l'armée américaine c'est vrai que ce qui
frappe lorsqu'on voit ce documentaire on
a affaire à des libérateurs or les
violences sexuelles les viols en temps
de guerre sont souvent le fautes des
concurrents par définition
parce qu'il faut se mettre à l'échelle
en temps réel d'une situation
dans un village une soirée à un moment
donné où la vie politique internationale
est un peu éloignée parce qu'il y a une
famille des armées qui a vécu la guerre
qui qui épuise etc qui est désormais
avec les enfants les vieux etc et en
face des militaires armés et conquérant
qu'il soit les libérateurs ou pas et
dans cette situation de de d'inégalité
d'emblée du rapport de force c'est dans
cette situation où la domination est
impliquée dans la scène même par les
positions des gens c'est à dire que un
militaire armé sera toujours plus fort
qu'une petite fille de 4 ans ou qu'une
vieille de 80 ans et donc c'est là que
la possibilité des viols des exactions
arrivent parce qu'il y a ce moment
d'impunité de vertige et constatons que
même en tant que paix c'est dans les
situations de domination extrême par
exemple dans des orphelinats vous avez
des vieux prêtres qui sacré le pouvoir
etc et des petits enfants felins démunis
etc dans les familles où le chef de
famille est un tyran etc qui domine les
enfants qui ont plus aiment le tirant
ainsi si tu veux et qui sont dans un
état effrayant et dans les périodes
d'esclavagisme ou la démographie de
trois continents étaient changés à cause
des viols pendant 3 siècles en situation
d'esclavagisme dans les immeubles du 19e
siècle où les petites jeunes filles de
province qui ont qui ont quitté la
Bretagne son sixième étage et où tous
les hommes bourgeois la famille font
leurs prosexuels et là les font basculer
dans le champ de la prostitution parce
que la honte bascule du côté de la
victime donc soyons très clair le viol
qui est une torture et s'inscrit dans
une situation de domination même à se
poser la question est-ce que la
domination qui infinie est toujours
physique de quelqu'un qui est plus fort
que quelqu'un en face qui est au-dessus
ne se termine pas dans le corps est-ce
que le viol n'est pas le le l'expression
même de la
[Musique]
c'est pas obligé du tout il sait pas du
tout une mécanique c'est ce sont des
situations de domination et d'impunité
mais dans ces situations notre culture
montre que la domination et la pour dans
une population civile frappée par la
différence des sexes puisqu'on est des
mammifères l'armée va traiter
différemment la destruction du masculin
et la destruction du féminin c'est pas
pareil le masculin on fait couler son
sang on les gorge on les tripe on
l'assassine tout de suite et c'était
vrai à se réveiller de ça comme c'est
vrai dans beaucoup d'endroits où il y a
des guerres même maintenant mais
traditionnellement même le dans l'ilia
des l'Odyssée les femmes on les emmène
on les épouse on leur fait l'enfant de
l'ennemi elles disparaissent dire que
pour les femmes comme il y a cette idée
qu'elle porte les enfants des deux sexes
si on la femme le meurtre de gens c'est
le viol puisque avec le viol on lui fait
oublier on tue le mari le fils le frère
tous les hommes de la famille sont niés
et piétinés dans le viol de la femme de
l'ennemi auquel on va faire l'enfant de
l'ennemi et la femme on lui fait autre
chose mais c'est quand même un meurtre
de gens et c'est quand même on peut dire
que le viol il y a beaucoup de viols
d'hommes et d'enfants hélas mais le viol
des femmes entendent guerre c'est un un
grand cliché culturel que le corps des
femmes ennemies pour le dominer on le
viole ce qu'on a constaté dans ce film
n'est malheureusement pas propre au dji
lors de la libération
russe lorsqu'ils ont avancé
sur le territoire de l'Allemagne nazie
il y a notamment aux Allemands lorsqu'il
eux-mêmes avaient livré la guerre à
l'Union soviétique
elle touche aussi l'armée française et
vous êtes un particulièrement intéressé
au corps expéditionnaire français qui a
opéré en Italie entre on va dire 1943 et
1944 avec
à l'issue de ces travaux c'est quelques
chiffres vous suggérez que 3000 à 5000
violes ont été commis par ce corps
expéditionnaire français durant cette
campagne d'Ital sachant que ce corps
expéditionnaire français avait lui aussi
cette spécificité d'être principalement
constitué de soldats issus du Maghreb et
notamment concernant ce corps
expéditionnaire essentiellement de
marocain a pu de 60% environ autrement
dit l'armée française elle aussi a
proférée ce type de viol en temps de
guerre et notamment durant cette seconde
guerre mondiale
effectivement encore expéditionnaire
française commet des viols 3000 à 5000
toujours je reviens c'est compliqué
d'évaluer et surtout dans un temps très
court c'est essentiellement mais juin
1944 auter une guerre d'usure très
longue où les soldats piétines sont
embourbés
s'impatiente une opération
où les Français jouent un rôle très
important
rompre les lignes de défense allemande
avance ensuite la fameuse bataille de
Monte-Cassino était décisive en Italie
[Musique]
incapable de défendre ses propres femmes
ses propres filles et certains donc
commettent commettent ces Violles
207 de ces soldats français seront jugés
pour violon sexuelles 39 de ces hommes
seront acquittés le plus souvent de
preuves et vaincu soldats seront
exécutés parce qu'ils ont été pris en
flagrant délit et néanmoins vous dites
le commandement français a clairement
entretenu l'esprit de revanche des
troupes à l'égard des Italiens qui
avaient entre guillemets trahi la France
le commandement français a fermé les
yeux le commandement français c'était
pas n'importe qui c'était le général
Juin qui devient un héros de la
Libération en France en 44 45 en plus
cette idée qu'il y aurait eu une carte
blanche de 50 heures qui aurait été
accordées aux troupes françaises qui
auraient permis ces violences d'être
commises alors évidemment on ne trouve
pas de traces dans les archives d'une
telle carte blanche avec une partie des
choses qui ne sont pas consignées par
écrit ce que l'on peut voir c'est je
suis pas convaincue qu'il y a une carte
blanche au niveau de
au niveau de juin mais on peut voir dans
les récits des officiers des
sous-officiers des attitudes extrêmement
divers certains semblent outrés on le
voit il y a des exécutions sommaires
voilà il y a d'autres en revanche on
peut voir qu'il y a une culture qui est
propice à la Commission de ces
exigations de ces belles lancées
vous avez des chansons qui valorisent
l'idée que la femme qui va être conquis
va
avoir envie d'avoir des relations
sexuelles avec les conquérants
évidemment cela crée un contexte propice
à de telles violences sexuelles alors
l'état français tout de même acceptera
l'idée d'indemniser 1488 victimes de ces
violences sexuelles c'est très précis
alors le comble c'est que les Alliés
laisseront le soin aux Italiens
d'indemniser ces victimes elle-même
italienne alors ça va c'est le règlement
de la voilà ça c'est des règlements de
la deuxième guerre mondiale c'est pas
propre aux yeux aux unités
on laissera aux Italiens le soin de
d'indemniser leurs propres victimes qui
revient à chaque armée ça s'est imprimé
de juger ses propres soldats on avait
évidemment pas que le vaincu l'Italie
enfin qu'un statut de comédie géant
puisse juger enfin ça c'est une question
de souveraineté en revanche en fonction
en vertu du Règlement de la guerre c'est
l'État italien qui devra indemniser qui
à partir du moment où il réalise qu'il
devrait indemniser et un peu moins
enclin à poursuivre ses recherches alors
c'est méfait commis par l'armée
française on a évoque évidemment la
campagne d'Italie avec Julie LeGac on
pourrait évoquer évidemment la guerre
d'Algérie et d'autres endroits où je
disais la limite disait que
9 femmes sur 10 qui ont été interrogées
par les forces françaises à l'époque ont
été violées tout de même mais
pour ne parler que ce épisode ce que ce
que je trouve ce que ce travail à
remarquable et bravo de l'avoir fait il
montre quelque chose donc 60% des
soldats
j'allais dire coupablement responsable
sont de culture marocaine au début donc
ça montre bien comment finalement il
faut faire face à ça il faut faire face
comment finalement il y a une double
culture qui incite plus ou moins
consciemment au viol il y a cette
fameuse culture patriarcale qui fait
même quand elle te dit non elle pense
oui que partage les Français que
partagent les anarchistes que partage
les athées etc plus une culture parfois
religieuse qui peut être d'ailleurs
évangélique qu'on peut trouver partout
mais qu'on peut trouver un point
vraiment inscrit et naturalisé dans
certaines autres cultures et donc ils
disent la femme que tu es en face de toi
est un demi-être humain c'est pas un
être humain à part entière parce que
quand il y a sous évaluation et donc
racisme envers le sexe féminin j'aime
pas le mot sexisme mais quand tout
naturellement dire c'est religieux c'est
Dieu qui l'a dit c'était naturalisé à
l'extrême donc le soldat qui relève de
cette culture c'est pas qu'il est plus
méchant qu'un autre c'est que dans son
système de croyance bon ben il y a les
hommes alors on se bat à égalité et les
femmes c'est moins que rien et en plus
ce que je vais commettre contre elle
c'est elle qui sont coupables et c'est
ça qui est avec ce crime qui est très
particulier et très lourd à porter c'est
que il renverse la culpabilité sur la
honte d'être salie c'est les crimes de
souillure et la honte vis-à-vis des
hommes de la famille qui souvent vont
rejetés dans les camps de réfugiés la
jeune fille violée de 16 ans le père qui
devrait la protéger ça lui fait honte il
la jette le mari il peut plus voir sa
femme alors qu'il est pas forcément
religieux ni rien du tout l'effet de
honte repose sur le féminin et donc sur
les femmes et donc elle s'enfuit et
c'est elle qui porte ça donc vous voyez
le confort je dirais culturel et moral
le confort du violeur effectivement dans
l'esprit de corps les copains on voit
très bien ça dans le livre de
Christopher Broni là c'est pas du tout
pour des viols mais c'est pour les
assassinats enfin de la guerre d'une de
cette de ce groupe de policiers
réservistes de Hambourg qui vont
finalement être impliqués dans des
crimées froyables contre des milliers de
Juifs etc que l'esprit de corps vient
juste à ça parce qu'on a parlé d'alcool
tous les soirs
manger ensemble ici vous voulez ne pas
le faire ne le faites pas il y a ceux
que ça dégoûte les manger ensemble les
copains partager celui qui le fait pas
c'est d'abord c'est une navette ensuite
c'est un traître à l'esprit de corps et
des boire ensemble le tous les soirs
dans le génocide rwandais il y avait les
beuveries du soir avec les choses qu'on
a volé aux gens qu'on a assassiné et les
repas et on peut dire que finalement
l'alcoolisation collective dans ces
cas-là c'est vraiment une lessiveuse
morale ce que le lendemain l'éthique du
copain c'est avec les copains et on
salit les mains et on y va et celui qui
est pas d'accord c'est une navette et
lui aussi on va le violet parce que suis
pas d'accord et c'est vrai aussi je
dirais avec les Wagner de Prigogine
c'est la même idéologie permaccio donc
ce que je trouve vraiment important
c'est attention de ne pas caricaturer
tel ou telle groupe de
soldats qui auraient tendance peut-être
à pratiquer plus facilement ce genre de
crime contre l'humanité mais par contre
bien voir que les cultures la culture du
viol dans une Europe dans un dans de
nombreuses sociétés différentes entre
elles la culture du viol tant à faire de
la femme la coupable de ce dont elle est
victime dans ce documentaire des des
violeurs sont jugés
certains Français ont été jugés aussi
dans ce corps expéditionnaire en Italie
et c'est pourtant l'impunité qui prévaut
donc c'est une image qui est rendue par
les armées concernées on juge un certain
nombre d'entre eux néanmoins ça ça
résout pas le problème puisque c'est
tout de même une forme d'impunité qui
prévaut
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
peut-être en regardant ses procès voilà
ce que je veux dire
effectivement l'armée française a
parfois rejeté la faute sur les soldats
marocains sur une culture de la radio le
fait non c'était impossible de les
contrôler d'ailleurs
les Italiens ont retenu ont retenu ce
terme sauf que c'est même hommes qui
combattent en Italie vont ensuite
combattre en France et combattre en
Allemagne et on observe qu'en France il
y a extrêmement peu de viols qui sont
commis donc effectivement pas le même
rapport à la population française mais
on voit aussi il y a certainement pas la
même attitude de l'encadrement qui est
capable de contrôler c'est-à-dire qu'à
partir d'un moment où il y a des
violences sexuelles en nombre il y a une
faillite de l'encadrement ça je pense
que c'est vraiment très bien
on peut penser que ça reste un tabou
dans l'armée française les violences en
temps de guerre et vous dites non ce
n'est pas un tabou noir mais française
en tout cas pour pour la seconde guerre
mondiale j'ai eu aucune ent de la part
des des
militaires enfin pour avoir accès aux
archives j'ai eu le droit aux dérogation
j'ai pas eu de problème l'interprétation
on m'a reproché dans mon livre d'avoir
accordé trop d'importance d'avoir écorné
quand même une victoire qui était
précieuse pour
pour l'armée française voilà on m'a
reproché d'avoir un corps-né on m'a
reproché beaucoup le titre le titre du
livre vaincre sans gloire voilà aussi de
montrer qu'il n'avait pas eu la croix la
gloire qu'ils avaient mérité ils avaient
à la fois commis des actes peu glorieux
et qui n'a pas eu la gloire qu'ils
auraient pu mériter puisque ils sont
c'est une campagne qui est assez oubliée
bravo pour votre titre
l'historienne que vous êtes comment
est-ce qu'elle voit l'évolution de du
traitement de ce sujet au regard des des
conflits plus récents on va parler avec
vous de la Bosnie-Herzégovine de la
Tchétchénie et bien sûr de l'Ukraine
parce que les choses se passent devant
nos yeux en ce moment comment elle a
évolué cette cette perception de
des violences sexuelles en temps de
guerre au regard des derniers conflits
moi ce qui me fascine par rapport à
l'Ukraine parce que je trouve
passionnant c'est de voir que
l'immédiateté de la recherche des
preuves c'est-à-dire que là on accumule
des preuves il y a des associations qui
vont essayer de recenser l'ensemble des
crimes qui sont à bout de chat on a eu
des informations tout de suite après de
l'ensemble des crimes qui étaient comme
donc on peut espérer qu'il y aura des
sanctions un peu plus importantes et une
meilleure reconnaissance des crimes qui
ont été commis vous faites le constat
qu'il y a une systématisation des viols
durant la guerre de bosny c'est ce qui
ressortira pour l'essentiel et qu'on en
est à parler d'une arme de guerre
lorsqu'on parle de violence sexuelles
aujourd'hui une véritable arme de guerre
exercée comme telle auprès des
populations
notamment les cernes vis-à-vis des
Bosniaques durant cette fameuse guerre
stupéfiant dans les années 90 et les
témoignages que j'ai recueillis dans les
camps de réfugiés ne connaissant rien à
rien donc je n'avais aucune idée
préconçue de ce que j'allais entendre
c'est le et le journaliste Goodman qui a
eu le premier à documenté c'est crimes à
utiliser l'expression de viol
systématique mais pourquoi systématique
puisque si on a l'impression que c'est
des choses comme ça de déruption barbare
en situation d'impunité et de domination
et donc et là là il faut faire du
terrain on recueille ce que disent les
gens ce que disent les acteurs
et on se retrouve en Bosnie au fur et à
mesure des avancées des Serbes dans leur
macabre
nettoyage ethnique violet les femmes au
fur et au fur et à mesure les gonfler
c'est le moins important qui est traduit
du cerveau croate qui est purification
ethnique ou nettoyage ethnique sur
lequel il y a beaucoup de travaux en
gros l'idée à partir du moment où vous
avez défini collectivement dans un
village ceux qui ont le droit d'y rester
parce que leur ethnie ce qui était
ridicule dans la Yougoslavie où il y
avait que des nationalités tout le monde
était marié ensemble contrairement par
exemple au Liban donc ceux-là ont le
droit de rester parce que si il
s'appelle sur leur carte d'identité il y
a tel adjectif et cela non et ce qu'on
doit en faire partir comment on fait il
y a plusieurs procédures soirées soit
liens dans la beauté de l'Est des des
dérèglements stupéfiants internes
interdit de sortir de chez soi interdit
et puis un moment obligation si vous
voulez il y a eu plusieurs situations
mais le les situations qui que moi
j'avais documenté qui m'avait à vrai
considéré complètement c'est que le il
semblerait que
dans le camp faucha par exemple les
hommes donc été systématiquement souvent
égorgées ce qui était un peu c'était la
mythologie
héritée de l'histoire turque qu'on voit
l'importance dans les pratiques de
cruauté de la culture et de la fausse
culture d'une dans une nation des des
faux souvenirs repris par la propagande
et les femmes elles de leur côté sont
gardées et on leur fait des enfants il y
avait eu des campagnes de stérilet en
Bosnie il y avait une situation de femme
les femmes bosniaque évidemment pas de
voix le monogamie la slivovitch et
campagne de stérilet n'oublions pas
quand même quelques décennies d'une
culture qui se voulait athée etc et donc
ces femmes les voilà assignées
ces viols systématiques alors qu'ils
sont souvent des tortures alors pourquoi
ce qui est faire l'amour pour le
mammifère humain devient faire la haine
c'est-à-dire que la haine politique
s'exprime dans le corps de l'ennemi ça
c'est une tragique moi mon avis qu'il
faut mais disons que non seulement
c'était punir détruire faire souffrir
puisqu'il y avait vraiment des choses
extrêmement comme on voit d'ailleurs à
bout de chat sadienne et pourquoi
pourquoi ce déchaînant et deuxièmement
le faire faire tu auras un enfant qui te
détestera cette idée que le fils
ressemble au père il va hériter même de
la religion du père des goûts du père et
de la haine du père et donc le fils
dressera contre la mère donc elle aura
l'enfant vous voyez le viol est un crime
continu et il y a beaucoup viol d'hommes
et d'enfants et c'est pour une
problématique particulière mais le viol
des femmes associe de particulier ce qui
est possible qu'il y a l'enfant à qui
est cet enfant quelle est cet enfant et
le travail des ONG après c'est mais
comment on se réconcilie il faut parfois
que l'enfant pense que une fois une
femme a dit ça plus seule que moi il y a
lui donc elle accepte de l'adopter mais
il faut accepter qu'il n'y a plus de
lien se Moïse entre eux le père et le
fils qui est une croyance à bas bruit
que nous avons quand nous faisons notre
arbre généalogique nous sommes contents
de croire des centres d'Henri IV ou de
je sais pas qui et donc si vous voulez
c'est une croyance qui à l'oeuvre et
dans les viols systématiques pour la
purification et tenir l'éradication je
touche l'arbre de Luffy de l'affiliation
je l'ai radique je le déracine parce que
l'idée n'est pas de dévorer l'espace
c'est de dévorer le temps que les gens
dont je veux qu'il n'existent plus n'est
jamais été là d'où le viol des tombes et
des cimetières c'est un peu ce qui est
en train de se passer en
Ukraine de la part des Russes pour moi
ce que vous êtes en train de décrire là
votre avis aussi j'ai l'impression
du territoire de ces femmes de sa
population effectivement il changeait
l'identité
exactement par la langue parlant et le
viol si un transfert d'identité majeur
c'est le crime de salissures si je vous
crache dessus c'est vous qui devez vous
nettoyer c'est vous qui êtes salit mais
le viol c'est vraiment le la possession
de l'identité d'autrui jusque dans la
génération d'après et donc vous voyez
cette dimension d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses génocide guénance en grec
c'est naissances donc pour
l'anthropologue le viol c'est violent
dont vous avez dit son nouveau c'est pas
qu'ils sont nouveaux mais pourquoi il se
systématique au cœur de l'Europe fin du
20e siècle univers qu'on voulait
différents dans les rapports humains
quand même mais moi ma génération
qu'est-ce que c'est et là il y a cette
dimension de vouloir anéantir au travers
du corps de la femme la communauté tout
entière dans son avenir le viol en
situation de conflit lorsqu'il est
répandu et systématique est à présent
reconnu comme un crime contre l'humanité
et un crime de guerre puis depuis 2008
le Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
à adopter une résolution qui établit
pour la première fois que la violence
sexuelle pendant les conflits et ses
conséquences représentent une menace
pour la paix et là sécurité
internationale et ça dire que la justice
internationale se donne les moyens
aujourd'hui de faire payer et de et
ceux et celles qui
rendent ces crimes possibles au sein de
leurs armées car encore faut-il
documenter encore faut-il avoir la
collaboration de la documentation c'est
rassemblé l'épreuve plus que ces témoins
je vous laisse parler puisque voilà ce
sont souvent est-ce qu'on voit pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale des crimes il
y a un espace d'un pionnier c'est-à-dire
que les armes et sont en mouvement il y
a peu moyen de retrouver les coupables
on voit bien que les victimes ont du mal
à identifier leur agresseur qui voilà
donc ils ont eu plus de facilité à
identifier les soldats noirs puisqu'ils
étaient moins mobiles précisément que
les soldats américains progressivement
donc la grande difficulté c'est voilà
c'est de et puis de rompre aussi cette
solidarité au sein des groupes armés
son camarade on va le défendre lui fait
voilà une solidarité d'une camaraderie
et ça on le voit partout vous parlez au
lieu d'une forme d'impunité aujourd'hui
qui persiste malgré le fait que dans les
tribunaux les TPI par exemple il y a une
nouvelle prise en compte de ces
violences sexuelles l'impunité continue
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on a signé la paix
entre de belligérants on ne parle plus
de ces violences sexuelles par exemple
il y a plusieurs cercles de l'impunité
mais ce que je voudrais dire même en
temps de paix ce qu'il y a d'extrêmement
difficile pour judiciariser et
documenter les viols même en temps de
paix c'est d'avoir les preuves or quand
même le la justice a besoin de preuves
et tant mieux donc on a une vraie
difficulté même en temps de paix mais
c'est peut-être un autre problème mais
en temps de guerre la problématique
devient assez énorme et parce qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est le
qui se me dirait mais les juges sont des
hommes les hommes politiques sont des
hommes les militaires sont des hommes et
même quand ils sont contre le viol de
leur mère et de leur faire ils leur
fille n'empêche que le viol d'autrui
s'en fiche bon on pourrait dire ça
peut-être qu'on peut le dire moi ce que
je dirais plutôt puisque il y a viol
d'homme et d'enfants et les viols des
hommes c'est absolument tragique comment
tchétchini on leur donnait des prénoms
féminins un vieux paysan tchétchène et
donc ou dans mes mais c'est aussi vrai
dans les prisons dans toutes les prisons
et là russe même américaine et donc le
viol de l'homme lui enlève sa
masculinité il devient et c'est une
chose terrible sauf que lui c'est pas un
crime continue risque pas donc il peut
le taire absolument et s'en sortir comme
ça bien souvent le viol de la femme a
plus de sens puisque il y a cette
différence des sexes et il y a cette
capacité de filiation mais ce qui sera
toujours très difficile c'est la
documentation parce que le le alors le
souvent du côté des acteurs on se rend
compte il y a des témoignages
quand même on force le soldat il veut
pas y aller mais au rondin mais il faut
qu'il y a sinon c'est lui qui es-tu
alors il dit à la victime dit que je te
l'ai fait c'est-à-dire ce côté de
prouesse de la sexualité masculine c'est
peut-être ça qui est vecteur d'impunité
culturel en profondeur dans des cultures
ou même nous en France on chante et
c'est Françoise Héritier qu'il avait
montré les chansons dans les écoles
janeton qui rencontre quatre garçons qui
lui enlève la couette etc une chanson
toutes les écoles reprennent ça
charmante la Rirette la regrette et
c'est un viol et on rigole et les et le
fait que la culture du viol enlève la
visibilité en tant que crime contre
l'être humain visibilité qui devient
énorme quand c'est soit sa famille c'est
mais il enlève culturellement fait que
bien évidemment y compris dans le monde
du droit les crimes sexuels ont dit bon
ben elle a survécu elle est pas morte
bon bah elle Vincent on va lui faire un
peu de psy et hop là et fait qu'on
minorise le tragique il faut donner le
nom de torture c'est une torture c'est
destructeur c'est destructeur de la
famille et de l'estime de soi c'est un
crime majeur il est minorisé en ce sens
il y a un des cercles d'impunité
culturel contre lequel on pourrait
vraiment faire quelque chose bien ce
sera le mot de la fin en précisant aussi
que le viol en temps de guerre est
interdit par tous les codes militaires
des armées occidentales depuis le 17e
siècle et pourtant on a envie de dire
après vous avoir entendu et vu ce
documentaire Okio que nous proposions
aujourd'hui dans cette émission un grand
merci vraiment à toutes les deux
à ce débat doc consacré aux violences
sexuelles en temps de guerre vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
merci Axel massali comme à l'accoutumée
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission et je
vous donne rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]